[Musique]
moi je construis des marionnettes
de l'homme
avec de la ficelle et du papier
m
son joli
mais
est
je vais
où les présents
ou les
deux d'entre eux
le
m
c'est bien dit
maman
comme son frère
[Musique]
rome
la pluie vient le beau temps
[Musique]
moi j'ai construit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec et
il seul
et du papier
[Musique]
m
je lis
je vais je vais vous les présenter
chez nous
à chaque instant
c'est jour de fête 2
parce optique une
ce qui nous fait rire
ben
alex a
ces pauvres bêtes
oubliée
oublie que le
m
[Musique]
avec
de l'artiste
papier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis l'ami
que je suis là
[Musique]
je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]